es ist der erste anschlag eines erste
ihnen den die menschheit als solchen
registriert hat zwar schlug der tunguska
suite in einer menschenleeren gegen den
rebellen ein
doch der anschlag war so heftig dass er
hunderte kilometer entfernt noch als
donna lichtblitz und erschütterung
wahrgenommen wurde
wäre er nur mit einer leicht geänderten
flugbahn zu einer anderen zeit oder in
einem anderen winkel in die
erdatmosphäre eingetreten
ja das hätte zahl der größten
katastrophe des letzten jahrhunderts
geführt es hätte millionen und
abermillionen auftrag gegeben
furchtbare zerstörung und wir hätten ab
diesem moment wahrscheinlich fieberhaft
daran gearbeitet eine solche katastrophe
zu verhindern aber kann so etwas wieder
passieren und wenn ja wann jetzt den
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen ja heute ist der sj day der
tag an dem wissenschaftler und personen
des öffentlichen lebens an eine
furchtbare und leider sehr
wahrscheinliche katastrophe erinnern mit
dabei ist zum beispiel brian may
gitarrist von queen und astrophysiker
nach seiner wahnsinnig erfolgreich und
musiker karriere hat er im alter von 60
jahren eine doktorarbeit über die radial
geschwindigkeiten im interplanetaren
staub geschrieben und seit diesem jahr
ist der spd auch durch die vereinten
nationen zum internationalen s day
ausgerufen worden ist ist ein
unglaublich wichtiges thema und noch
immer haben es nicht genug menschen auf
dem schirm der erde wird durch
asteroiden bedroht und wir haben darüber
berichtet sie schlagen ständig auf der
erde ein und zwar rund zwei mal im jahr
nur niemand bemerkt es als meistens in
dem viel größeren unbewohnten teil der
erde geschieht doch das kann sich jeden
tag ändern denn die nasa schätzt dass es
millionen erdnahe asteroiden gibt von
denen zahlreiche kandidaten seinen
einschlag auf der erde geeignet sind von
diesen millionen also jeden kennen wir
nur einen klitzekleinen bruchteil 10.000
deshalb ist dieses jahr die 100 mal
dekoration die 100 x6 ins leben gerufen
worden
ich habe mir gerade gesagt und das
solltet ihr auch tun der linke ist in
der video beschreibung es wird gefordert
dass aus diesem einen 100% werden und
wir in den nächsten zehn jahren alle
aktionen erfassen und damit die finden
sie sich auf einem kollision
mit der erde befinden aber auch an
anderer stelle kommt die sache langsam
aber leider nur langsam ins rollen die
nasa hat ende letzten jahres eine sonde
zum asteroiden benno geschickt der alle
sechs jahre der erde rund 300.000
kilometer nahe kommt und das esa nasa
projekte isa sz impact reflektion
assessment auf deutsch
asteroideneinschlag und ablenkungs
einschätzung soll den asteroiden die
dumonts nicht nur untersuchen sondern an
ihm soll auch zum ersten mal getestet
werden ob der einschlag einer sonde
seine bahn verändern kann es werde etwas
absolut erste mal dass die menschheit so
etwas versucht ja wahnsinn allerdings
wissen wir noch sehr wenig über die
beschaffenheit von asteroiden der 2014
entdeckte das weltraumteleskop hubble
ein ziemlich gruseliges exemplar das vor
den augen der wissenschaftler langsam
zerfiel 200.000 tonnen wog p 2013 r3 so
der name so zerfallen machen sich jetzt
seine bruchstücke langsam auf die reise
in verschiedene richtungen und teile von
ihm werden wahrscheinlich auch auf der
erde einschlagen beim tunguska ereignis
war die region um den einschlag herum
ungewohnt erst knapp 20 jahre später
dann eine expedition in das gebiet vor
und sah die immer noch sichtbaren
verheerenden folgen
auf einem gebiet von 2000
quadratkilometern waren 60 millionen
bäume umgeknickt der asta etwa nicht auf
dem boden eingeschlagen sondern in der
luft explodiert und hatte deshalb diese
verheerende wirkung noch immer weiß man
sehr wenig über den anschlag
2013 wurden angebliche bruchstücke des
asteroiden präsentiert die aber immer
noch nicht untersucht worden sind und
auch ob der jacko see der krater eines
bruchs stückes ist das bleibt umstritten
es bleibt also noch viel zu forschen und
vor allem zu tun wenn wir einen solchen
einstieg in zukunft verhindern wollen
und nicht zu vergessen erst 2013 ging
ein asteroid in einem bewohnten gebiet
den keller pinsk in russland wieder 1500
menschen wurden verletzt
und obwohl er sehr klein war stürzte das
dach einer fabrik ein es bleibt also
leider sehr spannend wenn er zum thema
asteroiden und den gefahren die von
ihnen ausgehen nichts verpassen wollt
dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
dem video über die zahlreichen anschläge
die jedes jahr hier auf der erde
unbemerkt stattfinden einfach
draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran